[Music]
my name is marques I'm KC and we are
this week's guests on truth or death so
we're gonna be telling the truth or
we're gonna be eating a super hot
definitely yeah I'm on my tippy toes
right now because marques is so much
louder than they look
yeah it's true always fine
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and welcome back
to another episode of truth or dab the
hot ones special where we give our
guests two simple options tell the truth
or suffer the wrath of the last app and
today we're joined by two friends of the
brand Casey Neistat marques Brownlee you
know them both as two of the most
influential names in tech illustrious
hot ones guests and overall cool guys
check out the YouTube channels Casey
Neistat and mkbhd respectively though I
suspect you're already familiar fellas
welcome back to hot ones good to be here
that's a great intro I appreciate that
alright let me break down the rules so
in front of you you guys have three
scorching hot chicken wings that have
all been doused in various versions of
the last dab yeah I have a set of deeply
personal potentially awkward questions
for each of you and when I ask you a
question you have a choice answered
honestly or escape the truth by eating a
Deathwing and Marquez we'll start with
you thank God okay you know you've done
really big-name interviews from Elon
Musk to Kobe Bryant to Bill Gates can
you give us one guardrail or a topic
that was considered off limits that came
to you before your sit-down from one of
their teams yeah I can yes I can yeah
anytime you do a big interview you have
some sort of lead up to it I remember
before speaking with Elon it was a sort
of a dicey time in his Twitter history
interestingly that wasn't off-limits
future products were off limits
unannounced things if I tried to ask
about the pickup truck I would have
gotten someone going no not this time
so uh yeah I can I can say there were
some things off-limits but usually
they're pretty good about it
swerving away yeah like you swerve those
potholes on autopilot now you see I was
a little bit of a softball there
Shawn well then how about this you know
you can swerve him to Casey nice that
same question to you Logan Paul
oh my mmm oh my yeah what was off-limits
there hmm okay there was nothing
off-limits with Logan Paul who was like
where's the camera
Logan thank you for being generous to
that interview but there was an enormous
amount of trepidation and this I've
never talked about and I hope Logan you
don't see this as a violation of trust
after that was shot there were several
phone calls from team Logan asking me
not to include parts don't go there list
of questions but did you cut anything
out I did not I did not my response was
that it would not have been
intellectually honest to not include the
whole thing respect like blemishes and
all all right so after round one we've
successfully swerved the wings and then
the conversation it is such a lovely
segue into round 2 over here marques you
built a YouTube empire on your call it
like you see it tech reviews but we know
the Amazons the apples the googles of
the world they carry a big stick
what's the biggest blowback that you've
ever gotten from a major tech brand that
either wanted you to scrap a bad review
or take down a video this is great
really gut this answer could potentially
damage his career no I just want to come
in I'm always honest in the video so
anytime there's something that's
critical about a product the best part
of it for me is it's always true and so
whatever their responses has to be based
around the fact that what I said is
actually true but I do remember pretty
recently I reviewed a phone from a
company called read me the front-facing
camera I called I quote straight garbage
in the video it was horrible but I'm
pretty sure it was broken did not know
it at the time got an email from them
you know pointing to their own fantastic
other results that they've achieved
saying can you make another follow-up
video or something like that and I
didn't do a follow-up video but you know
followed up on social with some more
testing all right
still swervin still swervin casey ooh
now to you and it's a fork in the road
okay you can either answer the same
question that mark has just answered you
know the biggest blowback that you've
ever gotten from a major brand who
either wanted you to take a video down
or scrap a review or what have you or
you could open up the QuickBooks and
tell us the most money you've ever
gotten to make a video or personal
appearance oh my god this is this guy
vicious luckily I skipped lunch today so
I think I'm just gonna
yeah have a quick wing but there you go
I'm gonna put a little extra sauce on it
I love that always commit well I feel
like you gave me these two questions to
choose from either agree halfway on that
one I feel like either me answering
either of those honestly would
definitely compromise my own integrity
so I'm just gonna put a little a little
that's a way to know what am I supposed
to get I think you'll scrape it off and
accommodate your own graves here cameras
are rolling just got to do it so I guess
that's a DAB
that's a DAB for old for all last out
over here
[Music]
oh they're like secondhand burns over
here I can smell it in the air oh my god
why would you make this where's a
scorpion edition mean we use the
scorpion pepper in this one you know
maybe we do it's time we recorded one of
these Shawn holy smokes
why would I put extra though sometimes
it gets the best of us here on truth or
dabbe but the Train does not stop
rolling it is time to go into round
three
Casey we'll give you a little break on
the question was that hot but not on the
heat because Marquez oh we need to know
what's the worst video Casey's ever made
I have to eat another one if you ask me
what the worst video what's the video
how source value our friendship man no
thank you mark has fallen on a grenade
for a case you know I like Casey too
much as good friends do I appreciate
that you didn't protect your sauce I was
just me being the ass yeah no no chance
them do that no chance
where you take one for the team but I'm
really struggling over here all right
Casey its struggle city but the bus it
doesn't pull over okay
you're obviously a legacy youtuber and I
can say from personal experience a very
kind generous and supportive friend but
it is time to burn some bridges and make
things awkward at next year's VidCon
ranked these youtubers from best to
worst I don't even go to VidCon this is
great david dobrik Oh Liza Koshi
pewdiepie James Charles luckily I came
hungry why is this like we're the nice
truth or dab say ten out of ten
sometimes it's just straight-up unfair
Riaan tastes like chicken
tisn't poison this show feels so
different when you're not eating the
wing with us right it feels a lot
different for me too I gotta be honest
feels punitive like what did we do yeah
why am i huh okay volunteered to come
here on to the next round
my words are pot all right marques what
is the what is the K stand for haha well
here's the Technic here's a technically
correct answer Oh getting away with this
technicalities and the K stands for my
middle name that's okay yeah fine
free of information requests his birth
certificate oh boy it's funny cuz I have
had several times where it's like almost
come up traveling internationally
they tell our passports reaching back to
us
you guys don't get to hear yet mm-hmm
soon so how's it legal to sell this
stuff it's like a bottle of mace
hmm Casey yeah you guys are both
internet trailblazers but with anything
that pops on the internet of course you
Father your fair share of copycat
channels and creators is there a channel
you feel owes you royalties there are
channels that I feel oh you wrote I like
I can keep the water in my mouth
at this point it's coming undone here on
truth or dab mmm I would answer if I'm
very gently I don't want to hurt
anybody's feelings right there was a
vlogger an ogee vlogger but one of these
guys you know yo what's up and then
about two months after I started
vlogging I started setting the camera I
started using a big cameras his name
everything change okay and I I called
him out on I physically got his phone
number I call it a like dude we see
what's going on here and because of that
phone call he and I have become he is
one of my closest friends in the whole
world and he inspires me his creativity
now motivates me the great jesse wellens
one of the best youtubers out there full
circle coming full circle and full
circle and I think if Jesse were here
he'd say the same thing here the gloves
come off because guys this is now a
head-to-head competition the first in
truth are dab history we are going to
head to head and someone here will eat a
wing because it is pop quiz time baby
right we are doing Tesla trivia [ __ ]
it's game over for old man nice -
marques versus KC nice dad it's about to
go down
how many Tesla's do you have okay all
right so three multiple choice questions
okay
and then if we're still tied after three
we have a tiebreaker fourth question I
hope it's what was the case then for it
is going down I'm gonna feel bad if I
lose this obviously first question what
was the Tesla Model S's codename during
initial research and development was it
Falcon white star speed pass or Kimbo
Slice write down your answers
all right answers in on the count of
three we will reveal one two three I
said white star but honestly I have no
idea
hey I put Falcon those are both good
answers only one of them is correct and
it is Casey Neistat Casey nice stat yeah
in the lead one to zero great question
as I'm sure you guys are aware Tesla Inc
is named after Serbian American inventor
and engineer Nikola Tesla which of the
following is he not credited with
inventing the first alternating current
motor the first wireless remote control
boat neon lights or the smoke detector
so you picked the one thing he is not
credited with inventing it's a shot in
the dark here for Casey and Marquez
on the count of three let's take a look
at the answer one two three
smoke detector and neon lights again we
have one answer correct here one that is
incorrect if Casey's correct he wins the
game if Marquez is correct he lives to
hear another question
Casey is correct two to zero in a best
of three which means one more wing to
cap off this incredible ironic rules
from our killer damn rings oh here's I
didn't I could beat this guy in the
Tesla trivia car was that even a Tesla
question really but not really the
question well played he's running the
board yes good luck and there you have
it
it's another truth our dab in the books
mkbhd Casey nice tat you already know
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah some said ahead other links of
spicy foods anything spicy I thank you
it means a lot to me that you guys came
out I couldn't have done the third leg I
feel great I would have told you
anything not hey what's going on hot
ones fans this is Sean Evans checking in
with a very exciting hot sauce update
our first ever collaborative sauce it's
here
88 rising first we feast joining forces
to make
dragon in the clouds you saw me Joji and
rich Brian mixing it up in the cauldron
yuzu from Japan etc I'm peppercorn from
China and of course you know your boy
brought the heat but don't worry we got
some professionals together to make sure
this stuff is FDA approved extremely
limited very quality and something what
we're super proud oh if you want to get
your hands on dragon in the clouds visit
88 night market calm that's 88 night
market calm don't miss your chance the
dragon you can fly away
[Music]
you
[Music]